[Music]
the hollow Earth and the excess Mundi
are two separate worlds that exist
beneath the surface while the hollow
Earth is termed as the home of the
tirant and even the birthplace of
humanity itself the access Mundi however
is a Dark Realm that exists between the
Surface and the hollow Earth both of
these locations are only accessible via
entry points that resemble vortexes and
wormholes so here in this video we will
showcase all the 20 Hollow Earth entry
points as well as those to the axis
mondai that are present in the
monsterverse we will list them
chronologically so let's get to
it number one mindo Philippines this is
the first Hollow Earth or rather an
access mondai portal that is confirmed
to exist but it hasn't been discovered
or documented by Monarch we know of its
existence due to the fult tales of the
Iron Dragon and its repeated appearance
around that region in
1952 number two hateruma Island Japan
this is chronologically the second
Hollow Earth portal that we can infer to
exist yet not documented by Monarch this
is where Godzilla resurfaces in 1955 a
year after the Castle Bravo nuclear test
which was an attempt to kill him the
hatar Ruma island is also called Monster
Island by Dr Suzuki who designed and
built the gar Ray emitter that led
Godzilla
there number three Kazakhstan this is
the place where Randa Lee and Kiko
traveled to in 1959 where they
discovered an abandoned nuclear power
plant built by the Soviets and inside of
it inside of the facility lay hundreds
of dominant endos swarmer eggs it is
here that Koo after Awakening of the
creatures was caught and dragged into a
Vortex that transported her to the axis
Mundi number four cancers us monar
discovers a similar anomaly in cansas in
the US itself and there they attempted
to travel to the vortex and probe what
is beyond it with a capsule that
contains leaw and three others this was
part of operation hourglass but the
mission was half successful as the
portal closed immediately after entering
it marooning the Monarch agents inside
the axis
Mundi number five Skull Island this is
the first time we get to know about the
existence of the hollow Earth entrances
as described in the 2017 movie Skull
Island well chronologically in the most
verse this is the year 1973 this is
where and his team using seismic charges
discovered fishes and the crust that
confirms their theory of the
Subterranean world we would see this
Vortex of the hollow Earth entrance for
the first time in the Kingdom Kong
Comics the place where Chas emerged from
it is also one of the most active
entrance points with the scar King also
using it as well as the skull crawlers
and the long dead KS that fled the
hollow Earth after the Titan
War number six Central Mexico so in a
map of Monarch the legacy of monsters
while that was displayed on a monitor
screen in the series we get to see quite
a few similar Geo attack locations where
the radiation spikes went through the
roof and these were potentially Hollow
Earth entrance points and also access
mondai entrance sites and the closest to
the US aside from the one in Alaska is
in central Mexico number seven Southern
Peru this is yet another potential
entrance point that is yet to be seen or
documented but it's seen somewhere in
southern Peru close to the ancient site
Weare Machu Picchu and maybe even closer
to another crypted Rich place which is
called Lake tiaka which is a lake that
is also shared by neighboring Bolivia
this is also seen in monar the legacy of
monsters number eight the Myanmar Coast
these sites here in monar the legacy of
monsters have been monitored by them
since 2014 after the events of GJ and
the mut battle in San Francisco this one
is located in southern Myanmar in the
coast which is also pretty close to
Northern Thailand number nine hono Japan
this is the last of the four yet
unconfirmed sites of the hollow Earth
entrances seen in monar the legacy of
monsters they are also deed as Titan
emergence points the one in Japan is
situated in the main island of honcho
which is different from hatara Island
since this place is closer to Okinawa
than the
mainland number 10 Alaska in the US this
is a confirmed site that was discovered
in 2015 and it was the emergence point
of the frost V Titan a gigantic
subterranean mole like ttan that feeds
on thermal radiation and has Frost
abilities this site was destroyed by
leaw and his team of Rogue operatives
number 11 Northern Algeria so this is
where Godzilla was resting healing and
recuperating after the muto Prime battle
and he was found there in 2015 the fact
that he was in the middle of the desert
sleeping for months and when he was
awakened he mysteriously disappeared
again Into Thin Air means that there is
a hollow Earth portal in this country
nearby to where Godzilla was found
number 12 Lo nest in Scotland so this is
the site where Tanis Leviathan was found
in the deep water lake it was found by
Monarch and outpost 49 was built around
it but this Leviathan creature can
travel in and out of the lock with the
use of Hollow Earth tunnels and it is
believed by many theorists that there
are tunnels underneath the lock
connecting it to the
Sea number 13 the South American Coast
so in kotm after signaling a warning to
Monarch in the Castle Bravo station God
and a response team headed towards
Antarctica in 2019 to check on Gora
along the way they lost track of
Godzilla and one of the team members
stated that he disappeared off the coast
of South America which means he went
into one of the polls that hasn't been
discovered yet number 14 Antarctica this
is where Godzilla resurfaced from
beneath the ice sheet in 2019 in kotm
and Battle gdar For the First Time who
was just awakened from his Domin state
by Alan Jonah and Emma Russell this
suggest that there is an existence of an
entrance point there and later in the
next movie GVK 5 years later monar had
already built a hollow Earth launch
station on that same site of the
battle number 15 IED the mara so again
in the same movie where Rodan had been
awakened from Island de Mara that Island
near Mexico and was Leed into a fight
with Gora later gozel was already
enrolled to the place the fact that he
could cover that much distance in a
amount of time and Ambush or intercept
Goro while chasing the Argo aircraft
tells us that there is another entrance
in the region which he uses after the
oxygen destroy as well to go to his
layer number 16 the Mariana strange this
is another location that is yet
unconfirmed but has been stated to exist
as of 2019 since this place is the
deepest part of the planet extending
more than 11 km below the sea level this
tells us that there might be more than
just one entrance point
there number 17 the Atlantic Ocean
Godzilla Temple so this is the place
where Godzilla went to rest after being
struck by the oxygen destroyer in kotm
and when serizawa detonated the nuke to
revitalize the Big G the explosion there
created a Fisher as was stated in
Godzilla dominion and this became a ho
to the hollow Earth where in 2024
Godzilla Dominion Comics the genitor
Swarm managed to travel to it from one
of the lakes in the Hollow Earth number
18 Hong Kong so this is the entrance to
the hollow Earth that Godzilla created
with his Atomic breath after sensing the
activation of the power source deep
within the Kong throne room in the
hollow Earth during GVK this entrance
was devoid of any Vortex as it was
created artificially by Godzilla
nevertheless Kong traveled through it to
engage the king of the monsters in a
duel to the
death number 19 Brazil this is yet
unconfirmed as to the ex exact location
but the tropical seas and the fact that
the scar king would attack Rio de
Janeiro in Brazil tells us that this
portal seen in the trail of gxk the new
Empire is indeed in that
country and number 20 Giza in Egypt in
gxk the new Empire Kong would emerge
from a hollow Earth entrance point near
the pyramids in Giza as was seen in the
trailer he would also be pursued by
shimu the ancient Titan to the surface
the shimo part was cut off from the
trailer but we can infer that this
happened somewhere in the of the movie
as we can see Co already possessing the
Beast glove at this time so that's all
we have about these as of this current
setting now if you like this video then
watch this other one as well and do
check out our channel for other monsters
content we might just have things that
you haven't seen before like subscribe
and we'll see you in the next video take
care
[Music]
fam